et oui c'est déjà l'heure du dessert et
on va le préparer avec thierry chusseau
et son élève
marie courtin et oui alors aujourd'hui
on va vous préparez des cerises flambé
avec marie qui les cerises flambé au
final on va essayer de les travailler de
façon à ce qu'elle soit un petit peu
épicée notre islandais donc on va aller
travailler avec des épices cannelle anis
étoilé et vanille donc en premier et
bien on va préparer justement ce sirop
ce sirop à base de porto donc marie va
nous mettre une bonne dizaine de
centimètres de porto en fond de poils et
ensuite on va à l'intérieur venir
incorporer la cannelle l'anis étoilé et
les gousses de vanille la gousse de
vanille que marie a fondu tout à l'heure
en deux pour qu'elle puisse justement
s'exprimer dans le porto
voilà on va pouvoir passer aux cerises
donc on va les intégrer dans cette
préparation va pas les laisser très
longtemps parce que sinon elles vont
faire ressortir tout leur jus donc là
l'idée c'est vraiment vu devenir les
chauffer les enrobés de ce sirop parfumé
désormais et pour ensuite pouvoir
tranquillement attaqué le point de
l'autre et le flambage alors ce qu'on
appelle point de chauffe c'est le fait
de chauffer très fortement une poêle
pour pouvoir être sûre que cela ne
risque de s'enflammer ça va être très
très léger en sucre ça va être ça va
juste falloir pour intérêt de venir
enrobé lasri la caramélisées très
légèrement mais voilà contrairement à un
fruits blancs la pomme la poire ça va
pas trop se voir ce côté caramel donc on
va pas vraiment cherché une vraie
caramélisation ça va juste réussi un
petit peu l'ensemble
on essaye toujours flambée un fruit par
rapport à son alcool dont tu vas les
cerises on va utiliser une auditrice
donc du kirsch
on aurait été sur la nation c'est parti
sur du rhum voilà on va essayer
d'utiliser toujours les alcools associés
au produit alors en quantité on en met 2
306 dit on revient bien sûr la flamme et
on revient une fois que ça flambe
on revient à plat et on va finir de
mélanger alors pour mélanger forcément
vu qu'on a la flamme en même temps va
prendre la pince fourchette cuillère
très éloigné du poêlon et on va venir
remet à l'intérieur pour faire en sorte
que tout soit bien enrobés de ce parfum
de
le kirsch et de ce sirop et puis il ya
plus qu'a dressé sur l'assiette pour
déguster alors là donc en cuisine la
cuisine nous ont un peu aidé
ils ont préparé un entremets glacés pour
venir l'accompagner
vous pouvez bien sûr à la maison mettre
un petit sablé par exemple une tuile ça
ça dépend à près de 2 votre envie du
moment
et puis marie nous propose un petit
dressage un petit peu graphique voilà on
va essayer de travailler sur une lignes
traversantes une diagonale
[Musique]
ce sirop qu'on a pris du temps à
confectionner avec la cannelle l'anis et
la vanille bien on va aussi leur mettre
des corps dans l'assiette
ballanger venir assister avec vous
justement à la fin de cette recette
ça sent délicieusement bout oui on
retrouve tous ses parfums sa part fugue
depuis toute la pièce maghreb lama
grille malgré le masque on le sent très
bien et puis un dernier tour de moulin à
poivre
alors on est sur un poivre un petit peu
particulier saint paul de madagascar
c'est le vôtre si périphérie et ça ça va
venir
réveillez vraiment toutes les saveurs de
ce dessert sans la puissance piquante du
kof parce qu'on a beaucoup d'arôme mais
on n'a pas vraiment le piquant sur ce
forum
il m'a merci à tous les deux il ya de
quoi être créatifs et inventifs pour les
fêtes pourquoi pas ou tout simplement le
dimanche pour un bon repas en famille